so
hello i'm joel klein and this is
developing with wolfram enterprise
private cloud
um so i'm going to talk about
when you should choose enterprise
private cloud for an online project
and um how you would make it work so
we're going to cover
you know what you can do with an epc uh
compared to some other choices you have
with other wolfram
technologies including wolfram
application server
and how you would make the transition if
you have a public cloud
application to private cloud
i should mention that i'm going to make
the notebook available
at the end of the talk and i did time
this
um i trimmed things but i got it to just
seconds under 30 minutes so i will stay
um and answer questions from the chat
once i'm done i'll try to end
a little early to make more room for
questions
but it is pretty packed even though it
seemed simple
when i wrote it um so
this talk is especially for people who
want to run a wolfram application
on a network and you may have a wolfram
application on a network
but it's not working for you there are
some problems with either the scale
there you're running into restrictions
or uh
you may really need access to some data
source or network
network resource that's available in
your enterprise
but is not available from the public
cloud
so what is epc just if you haven't
haven't gotten introduced to that it is
like public cloud
uh you put it on your own hardware
whether you own that or rent it
you connect it to data sources um
that you like uh since it's you know
connecting to
to the hardware that you're it's under
your control
and you can configure it as you're like
as you like you can lift restrictions
that public cloud has
i tweaked parameters um
to suit your workload um and a big thing
is initializing kernels with your
own code and we'll talk about that a
little more but that's a that's a big
deal for some people some people it's
just public cloud is not an option
because you can't do that
and if you don't know what public cloud
is um
we usually uh talk about public public
and private cloud inside the company
just because to keep straight what we
what we're talking about but
this is what many people will just know
as wolfram cloud
um and it's giving you features like the
notebook in the browser um
basic web hosting with you know
requests uh http requests that
can be served with wolfram language code
and background tasks that are written
in wolfram language it also gives you
your basic file storage and you can
you know access it from mobile apps from
the browser and from
you know mathematical from desktop
so typical things that get built with
epc that we've
seen customers do and that we've done
ourselves
inside wolfram um dashboards are a big
one
and this is i'm sort of um you know
painting with a broad brush
but as a dashboard i'm talking about
just something that
is taking in data processing it and
producing some
i would say canned visualizations at the
end
there is a variation on this i would say
kind of a data analyst hub
where instead of canned visualization
you have humans
responding to requests from clients
whether they're internal or external
clients but
somebody's you know showing up for work
getting access to some data
producing a report that's customized
with some visualization
so kind of like a dashboard but you know
ad hoc
essentially online courses are a big one
uh the epc can be used for and just
another use case for them is really just
an api server
you know i just need to crunch
a lot of you know do a lot of
computation in response to web requests
so an example could be you know
classifier
um you know i'm throwing a bunch of
images
at this epc and it's telling me how many
oranges are in that tree
how many you know nickels are on this
tray or something like that
um so i'm going to get a little more
specific about an
example dashboard epc
use case just as a as an example to use
to refer to later
so let's say we have we're running a
website whatever the website is
we want to know something about our
traffic
about how users are navigating it
so the data source for this is just web
server
access logs those are already in place
you know we know that the information is
there we just need to you know we want
to use epc
to build out you know a way of tracking
it so
the web nodes are already routing access
logs to centralized locations so we're
saying
we're going to install our apc and we're
going to have that
those logs also routed to the epc and
they're going to store them in some
directory
then a background task a schedule task
is going to wake up read from those logs
do some processing on it you know import
them from whatever format it was
maybe derive some information maybe do
some uh
some binning or some deltas maybe clean
some things up or
um you know maybe reject some
information sort of blacklist some
information that we know is like test
data that we don't want showing up in
our dashboard some some things like this
and then at the end in the visualization
part
you have a page that's showing uh you
know the results of this so
it could be a notebook or it could be an
html page that shows
um shows images so this is
very pretty much dead-on description of
something that
is already in the wolfram cloud that
i've helped work on which is the usage
dashboard
and this page that you're seeing down at
the bottom
is uh there's i think there's a an
embedded frame in here but there's an
html page that gets served and inside
that there's a bunch of
image links if you're familiar with html
so their urls but their urls back to
cloud objects
or moral equivalent of cloud objects in
this case they're
they're hard coded into the application
but that's that's a detail
but basically every single one of these
plots these histograms
um these are all api functions that are
returning images
after they've read some pre-processed
data
so some self-diagnosis questions you
might need an epc
if you answer yes to any of these
questions so do you have code or data
that takes a long time to load
are you hitting time or memory
constraints in public cloud
do you have data sources that you'd like
to use
but you can't really move them somewhere
closer to public cloud
um do you want the functionality of
public cloud but
for some reason like regulatory reasons
or just a sort of defense in depth
you know you really really need um those
files co-located with the rest of your
infrastructure you don't want things
moving over the internet and so forth
um do you want them co-located do you
have background tasks scheduled tasks
that run
need to run you would like them to run
more often than hourly
that is a restriction that public cloud
has that things don't run
more often than once an hour and this is
a little bit of
subtle one but it's it's a good thing to
think about and that is the public cloud
we upgrade public cloud when um a new
release is available
with epc we make the release available
but it's your decision ultimately that
you know to get the timing right of when
you want to upgrade
maybe you want to download that put it
on a test
server you know try out your application
and then when you're ready
um you know upgrade your production
application to the new version
um that one's subtle but you know
it's there so let's i wanted to look at
um wolfram application server which
andrew delay introduced earlier this
week
and compared that to public and private
cloud because there
there are uh definite use cases for all
of these
and you really just need to examine your
own needs and see where where you lie
so um all three of these are going to
support basically
basics of serving of websites
and you know writing http responses in
wolfram language
notebooks are a differentiator wasp does
not have notebooks it's just not part of
its mission
um public and private cloud this is a
core part of its mission
um background tasks wasp does not
currently have whereas the cloud does
since wass is based on web mathematica
it in it there is uh
plenty of people using msp the
mathematica server pages that that are
available in web mathematica
it does support that the cloud does not
support that
there are definitely ways to get the
same functionality in cloud but if you
have
you know legacy msp pages you've
invested a lot in
wass is is the choice there they all
have file storage
um presently i'd give the edge to
you know the cloud as far as ease of use
of accessing the files
all the different options that they're
already available wasp is
pretty new so it hasn't developed
but but you know you can do it
permission control
and this goes with users wasp does not
have users
and therefore there's no need for
permission controls this is a conscious
decision because wasa's core mission is
really
high throughput api serving
and the assumption was
very much like web mathematica is that
you have a single application that
you're deploying
um you're under complete control
of or the application is under your
complete control
so there's no need to differentiate one
user from another
and that does add some overhead so it's
not there in wasps
so that you know the throughput can be
met
public cloud and epc does have that now
there's some use cases
um where you know you you want users and
so you choose an epc over wasps
um the kernel initialization that i
mentioned before
so wass and epc have that public cloud
doesn't and
i should just note what i mean by custom
kernel initialization this has to do
with
at the beginning of a kernel's lifetime
code that gets loaded then so if your
mission is to serve web requests what
you don't want to do on every single
request
is load 40 megabytes of code uh in was
an epc
if you've got some giant machine
learning classifier you've got some
giant neural network or you just have a
massive amount of code which some of our
customers do that take
you know seconds to load it makes more
sense to
do that up front at the beginning the
kernel life cycle
and that's just not an option in public
cloud because when those kernels launch
in public cloud we don't know which user
is going to get a hold of them
at the time that the request is made
then we can load
kernel initialization code that you
provide but that's done on every request
so this is really about
um the beginning of the kernel's
lifetime not the beginning of the curl
request um
evaluations are restricted in public
cloud because it's a shared environment
we need to put a cap
on on usage but that's what you get back
when you when you have wasps or epc is
lifting those restrictions and self
hosting
um wass and epc are self-hosted that's
the basic
um idea of those for public cloud
this is an advantage right this is what
software as a service is meant to be
is hey i didn't have to go buy a
computer
i didn't have to do anything to install
an operating system or anything
somebody's done that
and i just need to put stuff on it
that's what i want so for some people
public cloud
um not being self-hosted is actually
what they want it's
it's just the classic you know sort of
do-it-yourself trade-off
do i do it i do it myself because i want
customization
or some other reason or do i outsource
you know this service
accessing the data sources we've talked
about you can access data sources in
public cloud over
http requests that go outside of the
cloud but then they're going over the
internet and not
not everybody can do that so this is
sort of a
halfway can't do it and can do it for
public cloud but you clearly can do it
for wasabi pc
i mentioned the upgrade style and public
cloud
upgrades happen automatically you don't
have to do anything and for some people
that's an advantage so
new version of mathematica becomes
release public cloud will get that
without you having to do anything with
epc and wasps you
upgrade you know at a time that you
choose
and just for interest the the basic
hosting technology for these different
things
was in containers epcs are in
full virtual machines public cloud
currently is on bare metal
um this doesn't matter so much for the
most part but i'll just throw that in
there
and and finally um there is wolfram
engine if you're looking
for i don't want to spend anything there
is a completely
you know bare bones option here to to
start with wolfram engine
put it in you know some kind of web
server and do that for
kind of developing an idea and then you
know
once it looks like you're going to be
able to deploy a product
you know come talk to us about licensing
but that is an option
that's that's pretty interesting it's uh
it's very lightweight download and if
you haven't tried it
it's interesting so
let's talk about how to transition from
an application that's in public cloud to
private cloud or
as you can say moving out of an
apartment into your first cloud home
right if you think of epc as buying a
home
um you do need to plan it you need to
assess your needs and plan it
and then you'll configure it and move
your code and this
is sort of the core new stuff
that is hard information that's hard to
find the sort of the core of the talk
um so there's three big questions you
need to think about
you know your own hardware or a cloud
provider
how big or beefy or just what profile of
servers do you need you need to assess
you know how much ram and everything the
servers are going to have
how many do you need and then how many
kernels of each type do you need
this is what we're going to talk about
for a few minutes um
and but answering all these has to go
back to understanding what you're trying
to do what is my application's
architecture
and what size and scale do i expect now
and in the future
you know if i'm successful or as time
goes by
how does it scale and how do i need to
plan for that because you may
you may get away with uh you know two
kernels today but if you're successful
then you'll need more and you want to
you know have some headroom for that
it's just like
you know buying a pc oh i need
four terabytes of storage like okay well
then you get a new digital camera or a
video
um set of video cameras and all of a
sudden you need double that you know
you got to think about what you're doing
where you're going so
the kernel pools
cloud has three different pools of
kernels that at any one time there's a
certain number
of these kernels in each pool
and then as they're needed they're taken
from the pool
used either destroyed and then replaced
with a fresh kernel
or in some cases they're they're
recycled
so the three types are session
deployment and task
session are four session notebooks so if
you're in a session
and you are you know assigning x to
a classifier or some data and then
you're adding to it in the next step
you're in a session there's one one
kernel per session because that's
that's how people are used to using it
the deployment kernels of public cool
public kernels are a little more
complicated
these are used in response to http
requests and responses
mostly um so those would be your api
function form function
cloud evaluate every time a request
comes in
like i want a cloud evaluate we say
get a public kernel do the evaluation
destroy it return it to you know get a
new one from the pool
so the number that you need here
really depends on the factors of how
often
are you expecting api functions um
you know if you're using form functions
for a class
are the forms to be used during class
time are they expected to be used during
the evening hours when people are using
they're doing homework um you know
it's just a sort of a queuing theory so
you know
running a restaurant you know when's the
lunch hour rush and how many do we need
at our peak
kind of a question they're also used for
deployed notebooks and for deployed
notebooks they're used if you're using
dynamics manipulates they may also
be used for computing some helper data
for graphics
and these you kind of need to play with
it a little bit just try it out what's
my typical
deployed notebook um how much kernel
time is it using uh to get an idea of
how many of those you need and similar
question is for the apis
and you should be aware that these
kernel the squirrel pool is used for
some system stuff
uh for making the html caches of
notebooks and also there's these
content-based icons that get rendered um
there's some level of that in the
background
and you know when you're planning an epc
you can come to us
and ask these questions and and we'll
help you know evaluate what
um what your needs would be then there's
finally there's the task
pool for services these are used for
scheduled tasks and basically things
that don't
think you know they're not the first two
categories they're things that are
running in the background
and then you know this is usually easier
to estimate because they are done
on a schedule so you know once an hour
i'm doing this processing or
i've got one that's going to run you
know three of them that are going to run
uh to track these you know to split load
between these different data sources
something like that
uh in if you've got just static cloud
files don't
that don't use kernels they don't use
kernels um so that doesn't have to
you know affect anything uh
and then as far as number of nodes you
should be aware that there's kind of two
main ways of running epc one is single
node
everything fits on on a node and i would
say eight kernels
or less is single node scenario
most modern servers you know can do that
just fine
as a matter of fact my laptop or my
development desktop can run any
can run two or three epcs that have
eight
kernels just on its own they're not
heavily loaded
but as far as the ram footprint and
everything
um they will fit um
so anyway single node uh versus a
cluster the way that the cluster works
is you have one master node that runs
all the services so your database your
web server your load balancer
as well as the notebook that you
configure with and of course kind of
orchestrate configuration from
onenote is taken for that and then you
have one or more compute nodes
and the and you add compute nodes add or
remove compute nodes
you know as you need to scale
um so
we have this dashboard epc example
let's just go as an exercise through
this um
so this is the same bullet points i had
before and just added highlights for
you know planning um
so we had you know what was already in
place was the web nodes
with uh with logging and we said that we
were going to have
the logging get redirected to the epc as
well and store them in a directory
so okay we're storing something
we need to plan for the storage and you
you might say like well
after the logs are sort of processed we
don't need them anymore we're really
only going to
you know use a certain basically a
constant amount a fixed amount we're not
going to accumulate those you know
so you have to think about that you know
just what is your data need
then you have a scheduled task that's
going to process those so you need one
task kernel for that
check um you know at least one
i guess is what this means and then you
have your dashboard and i said before
that there's kind of two options here
one is just a notebook another one is
api function
so between these two options you can see
at least one public kernel
is going to be needed but really you
know it's also going to depend on how
many people are accessing this dashboard
at the time
so just a little more detail on this
um how much data is arriving over time
how much law is in these logs that's
arriving
every hour and for whatever your
processing
is can you process it in an hour
you know in under an hour or not if you
are taking more than an hour to process
it and you're not keeping up and you
need to add
compute time or do something to to make
it so that you can process you can
keep up um sort of like an i love lucy
at the
chocolate factory when they're getting
more chocolates and then they can
process
hilarity ensues um
how long is the raw data needed i i kind
of uh
alluded to that you know maybe you keep
it around as a safety buffer a few days
but
hopefully you're not keeping this around
a lot
um you know what is your storage
footprint
how often is the dashboard accessed and
by how many unique users maybe you're in
a situation where
um you just have a few executives um
and managers that need to look at your
dashboard
so but you know you
it's really important that when any one
of them wants it
um that they can get it that they're not
timing each other out so if you have
five people that absolutely have to see
this dashboard then plan for that
um there there are some other ways to
to to do this this dashboard the um
in this scenario look up auto refreshed
it's sort of a combination of
a scheduled task but it's a scheduled
task that produces something like a
notebook
and then you know the notebook can
possibly be viewed
by many people at once without really
needing
any more kernels or or something like
that or
delayed has a caching option so you can
produce images with a delayed
that cache their data for 10 minutes or
something
and not use a kernel so there are a lot
of options and once you get into
actually implementing these
some of these things that i've never
heard of that some of these things
actually become very important and
they're there because
you know we we realize um these various
needs as we're developing
um so this was sort of what i alluded to
you know
what is there an emergency situation is
there a scenario and
and i hope if we've learned one thing
from 2020 it's to
actually plan for emergencies rather
than saying yeah that's something we
should plan for
and never actually doing it but um
is there a scenario where you really
might need a lot of extra capacity or
have the
have something on standby to add
capacity quickly
and again wolfram can help with you know
this type of planning
give you some options that that would
work for you
uh so maybe after all this analysis we
say you know what for our current needs
we we just need eight kernels
it's gonna fit on one server perfect now
we're ready to actually order it
and um you know get it set up
so here's our envelopes in case you
don't have any
for for doing your calculations on the
back of them
um i just wanted to walk through um how
you create the epc and i see we're a
little bit short on time so
i'll kind of skim this but basically
you're going to prepare all the nodes in
your
in your um you know if it's just one
you're going to prepare one node you're
going to put vmware or something on
on that node you're going to install
the virtual machine into the hypervisor
application activate the wolfram
products put your license on there
set up dns and ssh keys get an ssl
certificate because it's a web server
open the configuration notebook and tell
it you know
what it is it's dashboard.example.com
tell it about a mail server select a
database password
and then you get to the end the the
three big red buttons
um that generate config files install
them on system and restart everything
and then you're off
off to the races and you've got a cloud
and
this this whole process knowing exactly
what you're doing if you already have
the node and the vm um i can get an epc
going
in something like 10 to 15 minutes um
and that's with some fiddling around if
i if i was in a competition or something
um you know this
this doesn't have to be a big process to
just initialize it
if you're configuring a bunch of things
more than just the minimum
obviously it's going to take a little
bit more finally just moving your code
to the epc
right now this is not as good as it
could be
but it's not terrible and if you were
moving from public to private cloud
you may never have touched uh dollar
cloud base
but you're going to touch it now um so
basically
you assign dollar cloud base to the url
you know that's www dot the cloud-based
domain that you've configured for your
epc
and then you just do the regular cloud
functions
um most or all the cloud functions
also have cloud this cloud base options
so you can say as a one-off well
i'm using public cloud i'm not i don't
want to change my dollar cloud base but
for this one command i want to run it on
this other cloud
so ultimately moving code could look
like you cloud connect to public cloud
download your files cloud connect your
epc and redeploy them
um this isn't as smooth
um as i would like it may not be as
efficient as i would like so there is
some future work to make this a much
better story basically creating an
archive of cloud objects as
all your metadata and you know
reconstituting it on another cloud but
but you can do this um
i'm basically at time so i'm just going
to
highlight that we've we've been
doing a ton of work on epc to improve it
uh with automatic clustering um
we have extensive documentation now uh
we've reduced the size of the downloads
from about 16 gigabytes nine gigabytes
by splitting out html files
and uh in one fifty six one the pending
release we are upgrading to centos eight
from centos
six is a major upgrade and uh we are
going to be moving to dr kubernetes for
epc
not today but soon
and basically just improving the
experience
i'm going to end there
and start looking at chat
uh questions do we have questions stan
so were there questions or there there
were none
okay um does that mean there won't be
support for vms anymore
um that is kind of what it means yes
uh the the move to doc kubernetes um
i think the idea there is that uh both
public and private cloud would
would both be using docker kubernetes it
would be a unification
project basically um
how much does it cost i am not the sales
uh
side of this so i don't know and it it
kind of depends on what your
what you're buying like how many kernels
and things like that so
i would redirect you to to them
so i'll stay here another 10 minutes or
so until we
until we end or the questions dry up
how do you upgrade an epc of the new
version oh okay that is something i
didn't
cover there is an updater um
let me see if i have something handy
that i can show but basically once
you've already created an epc
what you're going to get is a tar file
when there's a new version released
uh you install that into the vm
and just basically tell it to upgrade
uh things um
and that is that is something that we
you know ex use extensively it lets you
do things like
select individual components to update
which we sometimes do for development
reasons but generally you know for
for end users you just want to update
everything but the
what comes in the update tar is
uh if there's a new version of
mathematica with that cloud release you
get
the the rpm for that um it'll have the
the cloud application itself
it'll have a component that's just
updated packets
it used to come with the html
documentation which is
what you get when you're in the web
product
and you go to documentation but by
default now
that is wired up to
reference.wolfram.com so you use the
html documentation
only in a case where you don't want
network connectivity or something like
that
and sometimes the updater has some other
things
so yeah brad is is offering his name as
a contact for uh pricing
uh when do i need to move from a wolf
from engine running a docker container
on my server tubal from application
server
um
i mean if you think kubernetes will help
um
that's one answer another answer would
be that uh
wolfram application server comes does
come with um
a paclet that lets you manage things
from the desktop
is very similar to the cloud functions
in the sense that it's a packet
updatable
um you know in language way of
of of inspecting and pushing and
updating
basically managing your installation so
i imagine that's something you've had to
provision yourself if you don't have
very many endpoints you may not need
that
uh yep it is linux based right now it is
it is primarily centos or only centos
um but there have been some one-offs
that are that are big projects where
we've looked at
you know running on some variations i
would say we haven't done that it's
mainly
the vm and in a particular version of
centos
yeah i guess i can field questions about
wolfram application server too i haven't
worked a lot on that i
do have a small amount of code in that
and i'm involved in
in the the team that's been doing that
and there's some similarities
um the wstp server i don't have any
information i'm not really prepared to
answer questions on that
um can i use a separate mathematica
notebook to deploy updates to the server
directory
directly i assume since you asked abel
from application server if you're
talking about
that you're talking about deploying
updates to wolfram application server
uh daniel or did you mean um upc
because um yeah you can it doesn't
really matter which
um which kernel you you deploy things
from it's sort of a remote
a remote thing ah windows that's
actually interesting
it's probably a little known thing but
as cloud developers we actually run the
cloud web app on whatever
our operating system is so as long as
i've been involved in cloud
for some strange reason i never thought
it would develop on windows
i actually run the cloud on windows
and most of the developers
run it on mac so
with some you know with some caveats i i
wouldn't say that it's crazy
to say that cloud could run on windows
or os x
i mean most of the things we're writing
are um you know portable
in in portable languages anyway um
so it's it's not a big deal the the
differences boil down to
you know details about the services that
we use
okay so we just got a few minutes left
um
if you've got a question um
that you're on the fence about i'm much
happier to answer
questions of any kind on anything than
to sit here and wait
um so i guess if you're um
yeah anyway
any questions from
[Music]
any wolfram people
who may not know um
as much who am i rooting for in the mlb
playoffs thank you bob you saved me
um yeah my my team is
is long out it's very sad i i'm just i'm
rooting for
non-traditional teams not
not uh not the big city teams
it's they're all big cities but um i
don't have a clear favorite
just please not the yankees
um
anything else
what new 12-3 feature will be best i
don't even know if there's going to be
something called 12
3 and i certainly don't have a handle on
what all the features are going to be
if i had my druthers for cloud features
they would be some of the things i
mentioned like the the the backup and
restore
um uh and basically
you know higher performance and
monitoring those are those are some
things
and the actually the dashboard system
that i mentioned we're working on an
improvement to that
it's um it's going to be i think
expanded
in the in the next year or so but i
think the the docker kubernetes uh
is not just simply repackaging
everything in containers there's also
some architecture changes that i think
are going to be very interesting
um uh joel real quick the meeting's
about to end
for the attendees yep all right so we're
we're basically
seconds away now from from ending so
i'll try to get last question in will
epc users be required to devote a full
kernel to each of those three categories
no that's a great question
i don't want that that i definitely
don't want that to be a restriction i
want epc users to
you know not be wasting kernels that's
crazy
um so that that is definitely something
that
if if it's required now for some
technical reason that we lift that uh i
should probably
stop the share and um
and we'll uh
i get in the zoom meeting for you if
you'd like yep let's let's go ahead and
then
all right thank you
you